when you write something do you
imagine who you're writing for who the
audience is or you just writing a story
that is simply coming out of you I'm I
hate to say this but I'm not really
writing for the audience the same was
probably true when I was a newspaper man
actually so and I know that's the wrong
thing to say it's really recruit young
right or wrong answers oh wait sure
there are right well answers not here
for a new writer do you think that they
should write for what the marketplace
wants or write something that's very
close to their heart it might be
slightly different might be a
coming-of-age drama that probably is
very difficult to get made but they have
something very passionate they want to
tell or should I write something that's
more commercial
I think they should go back to the
trades forth and learn to become a
plumber really but short of that you
want a twosome you can do it too I don't
know I mean Oh My partner and I like
writing partner and I David Simon and I
have sort of been true to the story and
that we're following are following our
dreams or whatever or our passions but
you know I think we have followed things
that are not particularly popular you
know to the general to the masses yet
we're lucky enough to have made but
because they were important right here
of course you're being nominated for
tonight what is your favorite scene in
wine can you describe what the favorite
scene was and why that was available to
you I don't know I mean I think you know
there are some poignant scenes involving
we followed X number people including
four women who were
living in the projects in yonkers new
york and had the opportunity to move to
these townhouses these much fun /
townhouses predominantly white East
Yonkers and
I think some of those scenes were
particularly proud poignant to me and I
as opposed to you know there's a whole
political piece that was a lot easier to
write and equally point poignant I might
add but
I don't know that I get a single one out
you know I go see you last but not least
a much lighter question what music do
you listen to while you're writing I
thought that was a lighter good say yeah
it's a lighter question I uh all right I
don't think I listen to music when i'm
totally silent well
dead silent off in the middle maybe not
sometimes I did it something somebody
asked me last week what kind of what do
I drink when I write like a latte I said
no just black coffee ladik like coffee
and IV in fact but i don't know that i
listen to music where if I do it's you
know it's the selection i heard said you
know yeah auto focus or something i
don't know what it is